[Music]
hi everyone
thanks so much for being here today my
name is sarah walker and i'm a professor
at arizona state university
where i study astrobiology and the
origins of life
and i'm trained in theoretical physics
so i think about them very much from the
perspective of understanding fundamental
principles
so just to get started i am
really deeply interested in this
question about whether life has
universal principles as i mentioned
um and i've been working in this field
for quite a long time
so i'm going to kind of do a little bit
of a story starting from
um when um you know we're thinking about
the history of the origins of life
field and where we need to go in the
future and how we should be thinking
about this problem about what life
actually is
so being trained in physics
and thinking like a cosmologist i'm
really interested in the idea that there
are um explanations that we have for a
lot of stuff in our universe but we're
kind of missing the critical components
so
um if you look at sort of the physical
theories that we know so far and the
things that we can talk about in the
universe
we have great explanations for most of
the matter content in the universe and
some idea of what dark matter and dark
energy might be or there's theories out
there
we have no constraints on this process
that's the most like us which is what we
call life
and we don't know how much of it is out
there and we actually really don't even
know how to talk about the question
yet in this kind of terms um but having
come from
a discipline um where we want to think
about these questions in sort of the
grandest sense and talk about these
universal principles and laws i think we
do have to assume that life has some
universal properties in order to look
for it in the universe
and so this is sort of the framing of
the question that i think is going to be
the most important way of tackling
it and the origins of life is really
related to this what is life question or
how we can think about defining
life because it's the place that we're
really confronted with how hard this
question actually is
um so when we're thinking about origins
of life science um you know
the question of what life is really is
about the transition from non-living
matter to living matter
um but that's not necessarily the way
that origins of life has been
framed for at least the last hundred
years we do have a lot of progress
in understanding some of the chemical
details um so
the leading sort of set of hypotheses
about the origins of life actually go
back
now 100 years to the time of haldane and
apparent when they were proposing what
was called a
primordial soup hypothesis which is that
if you get
some chemical mixtures on the prebiotic
earth and
they acquire sufficiently complex
sufficient complexity they'll start
evolving
um into the kind of life forms that we
know today so basically you
just need a complex chemical mixture and
some evolutionary process to get started
and this is sort of the idea behind the
primordial soup um but you'll notice
that this is sort of a very much
the problem of life is solved by the
chemistry so we just need to figure out
the details of the chemical components
or at least how we can make
the ingredients of life on early earth
and then we solve the problem
and so this life is chemistry view has
really dominated
most of origins of life research for the
last 100 years and most of the
definitions that we have for what life
is are actually based on this view
that life is a chemical phenomena and
as i'm going to get to a little bit
later in my talk i don't necessarily
disagree
that chemistry is important to life and
in fact i think that life
um emerges in chemistry for good reason
because
chemistry is sort of the first scale of
physical reality with the kind of
physics that actually governs life can
actually
start taking hold um which i'll describe
in a few minutes
um but part of the problem with this
sort of set of definitions
surrounding thinking just strictly about
the chemistry and what life does
is that we end up with a lot of
paradoxes and a lot of contrasting
definitions so this is just a word cloud
um uh not to be taken too seriously but
it's
it's containing keywords in sort of some
of the most common definitions
for life um and this is actually a word
cloud taken from
a paper that was written about a decade
ago now
which basically tried to take all the
definitions for life and then combine
them
into a consensus definition by taking
all of the sort of most common features
of the definitions
and i remember when i first read this
paper thinking to myself well this isn't
science this is not hypothesis driven
we're not testing any
ideas about what the underlying
fundamental explanation for life is this
is more like
we have these sort of descriptions and
we don't really know what to do with
them
um and this is really sort of the
driving force between
uh behind most hypotheses about the
origins of life now especially with
respect
to the prebiotic soup are mostly in the
realm of these kind of descriptive
ways of talking about what life is that
then inform how we're thinking about
what we're going to do in the lab
they're not really
quantitatively driven and they're not
theory driven
um so what's the problem with taking
those kind of definitions for life
um well carl sagan actually had this
really nice example that
uh he walked through um in a paper that
he wrote um
a while ago about defining life where
he's uh goes based on this definition
that is one that you might see in any
biology textbook
which is that it's any system capable of
performing
such functions as eating metabolizing
excreting breathing moving growing
reproducing and being responsive to
external stimuli
so this seems like a pretty
straightforward definition um
i think most of us might agree that
these are all qualities that we could
associate with living things
but carl's point in that essay was
actually to make a little bit of a
joke about that which was if this is
sort of the defining feature of life any
aliens visiting earth
might think that cars were the dominant
life form because they satisfy all of
those criteria that we just had
um and obviously most of us might not
feel comfortable with that
but we could take it one step further
and say well cars actually have even
been
spaced so maybe this is actually a
viable definition um
so so one of the things that i think was
really um
well pointed out um in this essay
is well first off there is no viable
definition and i think that's still
widely agreed upon today there's
at least there's no scientifically
agreed upon definition for life
and part of the reason that's the case
is actually encapsulated in this quote
um from the same essay by carl sagan
um where he says that many such
properties are either present in
machines so he's referring to the
definition i just gave so
excreting and all of these other you
know metabolizing reproducing
they're present in machines that nobody
is willing to call alive are absent from
organisms that everyone is willing to
call alive
and so i disagree on the point of
machines which i'll get to in a few
minutes
but um but i think the the key point to
take from this
is actually that if you start from
trying to take the properties that we
associate with life
and build a definition from them you
always have cases you want to include in
cases you want to exclude
um and then when you work sort of
axiomatically from that to build the
definition
you always end up in this kind of
paradoxical situation where some of the
cases you wanted to include are actually
excluded and some of the cases you meant
to exclude
are actually included in your definition
and this is one of the reasons that
viruses have been so hard to accommodate
when people are talking about
definitions of
of life and why we have um
all of these sort of edge cases that
don't quite fit our definitions or lead
to these kind of paradoxical sets of
assumptions
and one of the problems here is that
people are often trying to tackle
describing life instead of
addressing underlying issues
or underlying explanations that you
might be able to derive properties of
life from
um so this is kind of more of the
perspective that a theoretical physicist
would take and i'll get into that in
just a minute
um but some people have like gotten so
exasperated with the whole effort of
trying to define life
that um they've actually gone so far as
to radically claim that life does not
exist
so andy ellington for example is an rna
chemist and i remember being quite
shocked when i was a postdoc
seeing given him him giving a talk um
where he actually
made this claim that life does not exist
and i think his point was actually very
well articulated
um in an essay by nobel laureate jack
shostak
um also a leading chemist in origins of
life where he says that as one focuses
experimentally on any of the defining
properties of life the sharp boundary
seems to blur
splitting into finer and finer
subdivisions so the key point here is
when you look at individual molecules
or the chemistry that life is composed
of you don't see the features that we
associate with life
and of course this is kind of
intuitively obvious most people think of
life as a systems level property
or an emergent property so for example
the atoms in my body are not alive but
i i as an entity in my life so somehow
we have to capture that in in whatever
it is that we're talking about
but it doesn't seem to be present if we
just talk about chemistry
um so trying to dig for deeper
principles is obviously something that
um a lot of people are really interested
in and
um you know in asking this question what
is life
we can think at least from the tradition
of a physicist going all the way back to
irwin schrodinger and probably even
earlier i know
many people have thought about this but
he had a very nice um set of lectures
that he turned into a book
um that he gave was published in 1944
um on the topic what is life and that
book's actually historically important
because it's said to have inspired
watson and crick to look for the
structure of dna which they discovered
along with rosalind franklin
um so what it what is life what was he
actually
asking well he wanted to know about how
physics and chemistry can explain what's
happening inside a living cell
and so this is obviously um a question
of interest
i'm not sure that the spatial boundary
of a living organism thinking about a
cell as a fundamental unit is the right
way to think about it
but asking the question about whether
physics and chemistry can explain life
is really critically important
and part of his own explanation was to
come up with this idea of neg entropy
which is that life locally increases
order
but does contribute to sort of
increasing entropy which is important in
thermodynamics
and that was sort of part of his
explanation for life but he ultimately
concluded that that wasn't really
sufficient to explain life
and in fact my favorite quote in the
whole book um which is
kind of motivating the title of my talk
is that living matter while now eluding
the laws of physics as established up to
date is likely to involve
other laws of physics hitherto unknown
so let's get to the point that
is really sort of the central focus of
this talk which is
when we actually understand what life is
i think it's going to actually involve
new laws of physics that we don't
understand yet and they might be quite
different than the laws of physics that
we know now
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you